sex how often do you guys expect sex
actually let's hear from the the married
guy how often do you expect sex
it's good because because a lot of
people have these ideas in relationships
and it's different than marriage so I'm
curious from your point of view
to me and this is gonna sound a bit wild
but I just don't ever don't ever expect
her to say no if I want to have sex that
is the deal that we've made as being
married and you don't want me to do with
anyone else then that's what I should do
and that seems to work literally on
demand is what I'd say on request I'm
not sure with this one because after
I've seen a girl for a while it tends to
be her who's always wanting it and I'm a
bit like oh I don't want to be like
there's a reason oh that means that
she's attracted to you that's good
there's a reason for that though because
scientifically men sex drive declines as
they age whereas women's increases at
the age uh yeah but it's not it's not
like my sex drive is a client it's just
like imagine you as a guy like how many
times a day do you really want to like
have sex it's not me it's it's not only
not only it's not just that that that's
that is a fact but it's not just that
it's also once you've hit it
and then you hit it again
it starts to you know what I'm saying
you lose that's what I was gonna say
about the variety so do you think
variety plays an aspect of that as well
um no because you can still be into the
girl but it's just that that energy
thing like because for me sometimes I
don't even want to like for instance
because I want to retain that energy so
it's just like oh we have to go again
and have to like use up energy and
potentially gonna if I have a bus I
haven't had sex
I think it actually just comes down to
the guy sometimes he just wants to bust
a nut he's just he's stressed he needs
to release that energy and he's gonna
and the wife is his release so at that
point it needs to be on demand because
the guy has a build up he wants to
release it well I mean you can't like I
can't turn on the water faucet on demand
you know what I mean then give head okay
I feel like I feel that Pearl you're
pushing towards how many times a day
versus how many days in a week do you
know what I mean no I'm just saying like
okay she's in a way you're an employee
right now there's this much that there's
like a minimum amount of work required
yeah what would you I what would you
expect
I would say there's no maximum and
there's no minimum it's what he said
just never say no never say no just
never say no if we're in a relationship
or we're married and if you want to have
it then I won't say no to you if if I
wouldn't have it then you don't say no
to me it's just it's fair that way well
I think Sex Drive is like very very by
men I know men have a higher sex drive
than women for sure just because of
testosterone levels we have like 117th
all the way to like 175th of like what
you guys have some of the time like some
men they want it you know three times a
day and then other men they want it a
couple times a week and I also think
that that honeymoon period you just want
to do it all the time on both sides
right so I think it depends the question
differently so we're in wife's what
we're saying like this is what you
should expect how often should you
expect to have sex in a relationship
at a minimum one to three times a week
that's a healthy marriage it sounds like
it three times a week minimum three
times a week be prepared for at least
once a day I'd say okay
when we're saying one to three times a
week we're talking individual actions
like
so that could be like once on a Monday
once on a Wednesday or once on a Friday
and that's a that's a good amount is
that what we're saying I'm asking um I
know you can say one to three times a
week is a is a standard marriage and if
well no that's not that's I don't think
that's a standard marriage that's a
healthy marriage so I'm saying I'm
saying in your ideal world we have a
wife School we're saying to the Future
wives we're saying this is how much you
should expect to have sex with your
husband
free to fives is it a week
three to five days a week at least once
a day at least once again at least once
a day once once a day maybe on some
occasions maybe maybe that their answer
is the correct answer but I would say I
don't think there's a number I believe
what these two gentlemen uh said earlier
as in on demand because on demand
doesn't necessarily mean once a day it
could be once a week it could be
um three times a week it could be once
every two weeks J as long as when the
guy wants it he gets it
um I think I think there's no number
it's just about that fulfillment yeah
when when sex becomes routine it does
get a bit dead so yeah on demand works
best for everyone even though on demand
sounds harsh but as I just described it
could mean it has to be said okay so so
let me ask you this because like well if
women are watching this you're just
getting intimidated right but um so like
I think this can run into a problem
where your wife is having sex with you
even if she doesn't want to and I think
that that's fair but I think
psychologically it can kind of you know
just like kill the mood completely so
what what is your stance on that because
there are times where you're not going
to be in the mood as a woman or maybe
you're stressed out or you know like
like kids and things like that so like
what level of understanding you know can
a woman expect from a man I guess that
goes both ways yeah yeah I mean don't
starve him you know what I mean like you
gotta you can't because then you can't
get mad if he cheats right yeah well I
think look there's different
expectations how you guys feel about us
putting our way paying bills supporting
in household or whatever it may be all
these
we expect the same level of stuff when
we're talking about physical intimacy so
when you're talking about old all of
these things are happening with kids and
family that's fine but does that mean
that if all those things are happening
for me as well I don't get sex because
of that like I still there's still
things I have to commit to well it's
like
it's like why you you
factor a genuine desire right so like my
point is this like if you if you are
married probably like to your first
choice because this is probably how that
would work it's like you can't wait to
jump as bones you know what I mean like
you have that and but I think there are
seasons of life where you do have stress
and then so is that really what you
would want is just like sex even when
she doesn't want it now however I do
think some women fully expect that but
once you get started you do end up
getting in the mood so you know it could
be like a five to ten minute situation
where she's like okay actually I wanted
to have sex the whole time I just didn't
know so I guess like that's what I'm
trying to pick your guys's brains about
do you want a woman to have sex with you
even if she doesn't want to yeah it
should be a duty because at the end of
the day you can't say to a man isn't
allowed to say oh I don't want to pay
the rent this week or I I don't wanna I
don't want to go I don't want to protect
you exactly oh there's a there's a
burglar you can kill her at first it's
fine like your man's not allowed to the
same way I believe a woman's not
actually allowed to if she wants to have
a healthy marriage or relationship it
needs to be like that you say that but
then if you are going to have sex and
she doesn't want to do it then it's just
not going to be the same like me I like
to have a intense session where we're
both enjoying it yeah
and the girl doesn't want to have sex
she's not really going to put in the
effort and there's not going to be that
little oomph and it's not just going to
be enjoyable it's just that once you
bust your nut that's it so I'm curious
just show a hand who would want their
girl to have sex with them even if they
don't want to show her hands oh damn
okay don't be scared to oh it's
interesting I'm surprised the
overwhelming majority here that you
don't want your girl to have sex with
you if she doesn't want to because you
can feel it Julie yeah look look I know
women who have been married like 33
years or 18 years but I I associate with
a specific group of wives okay these
women like having sex with their husband
and have like love doing it for decades
but like you you have to have that
genuine desire but that's the problem is
I think like women are ending up in
relationships with men that they're
consenting to they're not attracted to
this guy but he'll do and I think that's
how you end up in a sexless marriage I
think you shouldn't get married unless
you're both attracted to each other
otherwise it just won't work problems
come from unattraction if there's no
attraction I shouldn't get married no I
think they should get married they
should get married to ugly girls so I
think one should be married to ones two
should be married to twos right right
that's how it should be and now you say
that yeah but a lot of ugly guys
sometimes tend to have money and they're
getting with these really pretty girls
and then this it's a catch-22 and what
you're saying then that bumps them up
and then the girl has to pay for that so
if the guys are three and he's making a
million that might put him up to like a
six sometimes ugly dudes have a game
though you know what I mean like the
majority of the time they do yeah
you guys don't have nothing they're just
a body and that's it and if she's going
for money I think she has to accept the
fact that she's chosen money so she has
to also accept that she's chosen it to
be in a situation where she's gonna have
to have sex even if she doesn't want to
sure I feel like that if you've chosen
money then that's your fault and you
have to accept accountability for that
action but if you want to be in a
successful marriage where it's happy and
you're both attracted to each other go
for someone you're actually attracted to
that's how it should be I think when
women put too much emphasis on a man's
looks they're entering into their
masculine it's meant to be the man
that's meant to desire the woman for her
beauty and I think what's going on now
is women are expecting too much in terms
of men's Beauty and women's standards
for beauty have just dropped social
media has changed women's mindsets yeah
but y'all be gassing up these whales
yeah
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible